thomas bonjour alors le président de la
république va visiter la cave d'indre et
loire pour amorcer ce qui est présenté
par l'elysée comme un tournant social
dans le quinquennat absolument l'idée
pour emmanuel macron c'est de promouvoir
une réforme des pensions alimentaires
dont le versement sera désormais assurée
par l'état en cas d'impayé c'est une
promesse qui avait été faite en avril
2019 mais dont l'application a été
retardé en notamment à cause de cette
pandémie de coronavirus alors si on s'en
tient aux éléments communiqués par
l'entourage présidentiel afp le premier
semestre 2021 doit constituer une sorte
d' offensive sur le front social avec
plusieurs mesures présentées comme
favorisant l'égalité des chances
l'insertion et l'emploi et la lutte
contre la pauvreté un agenda qui répond
en fait aux propos du président de la
république lors de ses voeux pour la
nouvelle année écouter notre pays est
l'un de ceux qui est le plus intervenu
pour protéger accompagner les jeunes les
travailleurs les entrepreneurs ce quoi
qu'il en coûte
je laisse humain car il a permis de
préserver des vies et de protéger des
emplois
il nous faudra bâtir ensemble les
réponses qui permettront de ne pas en
faire un fardeau pour les générations
futures
mais pour l'affichage politique sociale
thomas mais en dépit de cette
communication emmanuel macron lui
devrait faire face à cette année à de
nouvelles à l opposition
oui ça commence dès aujourd'hui magali
en marge du déplacement présidentiel à
tour des appels à manifester ont été
lancés par des organisations syndicales
mais aussi par les gilet jaune de
touraine qui prévoit par exemple de se
rassembler à 11 heures puis de se rendre
à proximité de la caf où sera le
président de la république selon leur
tract diffusé en ligne
ma emmanuel macron est en visite à tours
pour je cite faire la propagande du
social après avoir détruit le système au
complet au-delà de cette manifestation
du jour l'actualité sociale pourrait en
effet être ponctuée de nouvelles
mobilisations cette année en plus des
manifestations de gilles et jo
mobilisation contre la loi de sécurité
globale des fronts syndicaux devraient
se former d'ici la fin du mois prévient
philippe martinez secrétaire général de
la cgt écouter l'épidémie a mis en
exergue des mots qu'on pointe est depuis
longtemps déjà la saturation des
hôpitaux la précarité de l'emploi
l'absence de conditionnalité aux aides
publiques nous avons d'ores et déjà
prévu des mobilisations d'ici à fin
janvier
le 26 dans l'éducation le 28 dans
l'énergie mais aussi contre les
fermetures de sites et pour de meilleurs
salaires
quand les salariés sont déterminés rien
est impossible si pour diminuer la
pauvreté redonner du pouvoir d'achat et
sauvegarder l'emploi
le gouvernement considère que la seule
solution reste de réformer les retraites
il joue avec le feu et fait un pari
risqué très risqué vous l'avez entendu
des manifestations nationales pourraient
donc avoir lieu d'ici la fin du mois de
janvier surtout si le gouvernement
persiste à vouloir réformer le régime
des retraites au vu du contexte
économique et des répercussions à venir
de la crise sanitaire ces mobilisations
pourraient bien se multiplier et ce en
dépit de l'exercice de communication du
président aujourd'hui à tours remercie
beaucoup thomas pour ces précisions un
exercice de communication lui président
que nous suivrons bien évidemment
aujourd'hui sur arte france